good evening members to our visitors
I'll stop reading that emergency
evacuation announcement in the event of
a fire or other emergency please exit
the building in an orderly manner to the
assembly point which is located in the
market carpark the fire exit in this
room is indicated by green fire exits
time delay the evacuation by premises
must not be re-entered until the fire
great I've given you all clear fighter
number one on the agenda apologies for
absence we've had Paula G's from
counselor mrs. lovely counselor mrs.
Mason counselor mr. Mason we have agenda
item 4 which is minutes of the meeting
held on the 3rd of 2017 which members
members happy for me to sign those
minutes thank you very much number 5
agenda item number 5 to receive
declarations of interest including any
number of clients who are films a
building contractor
model cook years building control
services with the Rockford and also we
can't have a building or planning
application in with the council and
we've been written to buy building
control to use their services so let's
go mrs. counselor standing not kill you
interest art a say on the planning okay
members I think of most members
distributing agenda item 6 which is
sanctuary housing we obviously got a
presentation that was circulated to us
which had a chance to to have a look at
unfortunately Chris tonight and it
really needed to be presented by him so
we did only find this out late this
afternoon so we have much time to
obviously to get the message out first
of all to everybody good but we are
proposing to just to put it back to the
December meeting so go ahead
is everyone okay with that okay so
moving on to agenda item number 7 which
is the delivery of what's for District
Council's Building Control services
we've got attending this evening
Matthew Thomas II assistant director of
planning and regeneration counselor
involved the portfolio holder for
planning a Richard Snape Building
Control team leader this is the redesign
services and the arrangements for
obviously having a chance to read the
report and that if you can just give us
a quick you know we last met and it was
on the 14th March so one six months ago
in that time the last meeting I came a
new structure was proposed for for
Building Control that was then put in
place I think on the 1st of May this
year since that we have looked to
recruit to the team leader post and
Richard came in to post we also had the
internal vacancies taken up by existing
staff so one of the assistant building
control officers became one of the
senior building control officers the
other post was taken up by an internal
candidate as well who has gone to
another another council since that time
so currently we are carrying two
vacancies one senior in control and the
other one
is a building control officer post like
with the previous report it has just
gone through the different works and
functions of the Building Control
Service as you will be aware there's the
fee owning and the non fee earning work
that takes place Building Control have
to compete commercially with private
inspectors known as approved inspectors
so they have to compete compete in a
market situation which is unique for a
local authority situation the
difficulties that we have competing with
that market is that you have to compete
with the highest salaries and the
attraction of the private sector and we
have to compete for them for work and
the difficulties with some developers
who use particular approved inspectors
for their work so part of the the task
ahead for us is to ensure that we can
sort of consolidate the service that we
provide and also take that work from the
improved inspectors where we can and
that's sort of our intention the the
initial work though that we need to do
is to recruit to the two posts that are
still vacant we have tried to recruit a
number of times to these posts and have
been unsuccessful with candidates one of
the problems that's fundamental to
building control is a lot of the
colleges and universities that provided
the accredited courses have not done so
for a long period which means there is
now a situation where you haven't got
that supply of building control officers
available that you would have had maybe
sort of 15 20 years ago so you know we
Richard particularly is looking at ways
that we
look to develop potentially grow your
own and we wouldn't be doing that in
isolation would be looking to other
authorities in South Wessex and and
beyond and in Essex to start to change
that situation because you know this is
not just Rochford that's experiencing
that situation but we have experienced
further difficulties because how our
wage structure compares to neighboring
authorities in South Essex and and in
Essex again so they're the factors that
we need to address and are addressing at
the moment to ensure that we we do
hopefully by the next time we meet have
full-time posts and no vacancies as far
as that service is concerned in addition
it talks about ways that we will use
technology to increase the way that we
can be efficient with the service and
that's using you know sort of remote
working accessing our ICT system to look
at plans approved plans you know
building notices when we do inspections
provide inspections online and that type
of thing so in general that's what sort
of been addressed up to this stage it's
it's basically an interim return to
review committee as was intended with a
further visit to review committee once
hopefully that we have recruited to
these posts I know that there was an
indication previously that the review
committee would meet again early next
year but I would suggest that it's more
appropriate to give the service sort of
at least six or seven months to look to
recruit and then see where we are once
we're in place with that and that's
hopefully embedded in the service but
that's sort of the essence of the report
I don't know if there's anything else
add from okay thank you very much we
have a pre-meeting where we discuss
reports and I know that a few counselors
have got some questions but I'll start
with counseling mr. Boyd that's okay yes
thank you Sherman this one so go saw
three questionnaires at our firm for
Matthew Lee don't got one probably
further funding over to you same thing
we don't read their corner take the
point leader at entry report and it's
report to us I'm a few concerns were
around I can't sense any business plan
around the old magic around it yonder
the only figures I've got here up the
55,000 which was he expecting service or
the 52,000 paramedical overspent for the
end of the year so I assume that means
there was a shocking place about two or
three thousand pounds surplus overall
but I've got no scene because we can
operator we can if we choose operate the
fearing service but we have to operate
the factory service I haven't I've got
no sense from this report how much the
actual statutory service would cost how
many people that would take and how much
that would cost overall if it's an
intermittent service or there's regular
work we would have to fund them if it
and how much it would actually cost to
do that as a bare-bones service or if we
asked car support sound thing chance
would to do that for us how much that
would cost and then to arrive at a
figure of and this is where I have no
difficulty
I've got no sense that we've gone out
there to test the market to see what
what work we could get in and how the
why we would what would do me a USP
compared to other approved in Spector's
I can't get
from this report or not cause it doesn't
give the sense he's being done and also
for so that's really it's probably quite
a build question and also I am aware of
the from what my clients say to me and
what other people say to me around about
reputation of Building Control me around
which is presumably a star phone because
they will say in the old days you say
can you come look at this and they'll
turn up the next day after that's fine
now it could be weeks and weeks before
anyone turns up which is called costing
them lots of money because they can't
intercede with their work
so it's recognized in here is that
purity of manpower thing and how long
would that take post recruitment and put
that right would you say well I'll
probably take the question I'll probably
refer to to Richard for a bit of
information and weight forward as far as
as far as a business case for that for
the first question but in relation to
reputation as you know this service has
been restructured and when we discuss
that in in the March review committee
and we have had times and through
sickness long term sickness and through
losing various posts we were down to two
offices at one time one at one time
because of the difficulties so that
created you know a difficult situation
for the amount of work that was required
and and to do the site inspections and
and to process the plans it was a
difficult situation and that's what your
friends who have builders may have
experienced I'm not aware that it would
have taken two or three weeks I mean for
a building control service you know
generally a client calls up and then the
control service would would look to
either on the day or the next day come
down and do a site inspection and that
has been the case for four Rushford as I
say there was a period where it did
experience difficulties but that is
because of the situation with the
recruitment or lack of a lack of staff
available to carry out that function
I don't know if Richard you want to add
to that and I think that was the case
but it was when I started the casein and
people were booking inspections and they
were limiting to them to a number per
day which meant that they rolled over
and as a result of atoms delay in
carrying them out so we're not doing
that anymore
so we've got we've got a running list
which we this is notify for identify the
review I would do prioritize those
visits
according to the resources with God and
we contact everybody if we thought about
visit is one that isn't there isn't a
quarantine might help them up so contact
the phone they've also also review the
the service given by the customer
services and found that there's a long
wait time for builders to get through
which results in calls being lost and
also staff miss reads the fact that the
list is quite long full in center
sometimes discourage people from having
a call so it gives us the on his people
the idea that they don't take the call
so what we've done is we've we've gone
to our national body and got gone to
their phone app which is now being used
by South End as well where you can look
it online which comes through an email
so that we're looking at that and we're
trying to resolve that issue and that's
moving forwards that's been quite
successful it's 17 calls today the two
staff that's that's quite a heavy
workload people been done today the the
fear leader no non-fee earning a
slightly more complicated all of the
services statutory but some of the
elements we can possible
McCord so I'll give you an example so if
we go out of sight and we do statutory
inspection of foundations and we pass
them
that's fear learning if we can't pass
them and we have to go back again that's
not a fee earning solar cell so slightly
more complicated for their peers removes
or Zamora so so that's that's some
plasti enforcement that's the
enforcement of austere local authority
has to do the enforcement so if it can't
be passed they've got to go back and
make sure that can be passed and make a
waiver adjustments required to make that
and that's the norm of the earning part
and we have we run a split on the
account so what is non feeling on the
earning so that we know how much income
we need to cover the theory part so my
wife eventually all projects it comfy
earning no all right so if you went out
and and you didn't you weren't able to
pass them you'll send that's not for you
and you have to go back yes and it goes
hard an Aspie record is non feeling okay
but then if you go back and you do you
pass them that's fear no it's not
earnings you had to carry out it
enforcement of actions end of line so
there's a sense of guidance which is
really in in a report which we can make
available to the member if required to
force it for guidance it tells you
exactly when you can charge for what you
can charge does that in that on that
basis would it be for the benefit of the
Builder all through it ever and to
actually have it fail so you
expectations when we go to site is that
it will be passed so we give advices
wrong to the Builder to get it right the
first time so you're talking about
something whether there has been a fee
so the feet would have been paid already
isn't it yeah
and then it wouldn't be fair but then
the subsequent visit wouldn't be charged
now exactly for
that's not charged in in terms of the
accounting procedures that are set by
self oh yes so it can't be that that
cost of that can't be recovered it has
to be recovered from the counsel and
often as a yes
but your original fee might incorporate
an expectation that X percentage might
have the follow up version of levels of
course we try to recover as much
terribly from the fee and that's why in
it you will find that fees and look
expensive but sometimes you know in an
area where the builders not very
competent or not very confident then you
might have to give more so more than
once how would that different differ
from what you what on this report could
called it the prove the inspectors
either private spec sector
no they won't work ahead of having to us
how the approved inspector works is that
they will only carry out the building
control function they weren't anything
else for counsel
in terms of planning enforcement all the
community else so they will they will
price the job per visit they will do and
then we would come and cost there are
more expensive than us and but then if
they have to force or fail they can't
they can't so they tender to us well
thank you how how a system works is they
can't they cannot enforce the building
regulations so if they go to site and
they find that over a period of time the
daughter is not complying they aren't
even even obliged to hand the work back
to us and then from the fault them at
that point we can't charge on the
enforcement and enforcement we revert to
us and we can't charge because our
confit
that's why understand the issues that
it's a little so that's yeah that's a 75
oh I'll get that
got that so that gives it don't run down
God
it comes still comes back to a business
plan help is there a business plan of
what the expectation is what percentage
of the market we could aim for what
they're what we what if we did get the
staff handle it would take them to bed
in and then what how much bad growth
should be is it just to get back to the
55,000 pounds service or are you
expecting more than that and what would
we do without viciously set it at 265
most yeah we wouldn't expect in this
area to do all the 350 thousand pounds
worth of income hmm we wouldn't be able
to do it with the staffing level at the
current we're struggling to do the work
as it is so to push the not the the
feeling account up to 350,000 we would
have to have ups expansion in the amount
of volume of work so it depends on the
economy what happens with practice it
you know what happens I wouldn't
anticipate that you could ever do all
the 350,000 in this district when
everybody compares on domestic
authorities with the size of a district
the number people you've got in it so so
if I anticipated a dentist office before
we could increase our market share and
we could have higher volumes so we press
the businessman mrs. Peris to pusher and
and in addition it all depends on the
quality and standard of officers that
were able to accrue to those posts the
level of experience they have if we are
able to recruit a building patrol
officer who doesn't need any additional
training and that's one of the things
we've highlighted in the report that you
know and I've said that it's difficult
to find at that level potential
someone who is fully qualified and who
will accept that salary level so that's
something we've got to take into account
as well in the amount of feeling that we
can get if we have to train someone up
because that will impact on on the level
of service we can provide also the level
of senior officer but we also are able
to recruit and you're absolutely right
about the reputation if you don't get
the right staff in the right qualities
and they don't help the builders in the
right way that ever to send themselves
well and calls on cupboard properly and
how others have given many people going
to use the service so it sort of
reinforces their problems so that's the
basis for this for what you're you so
basically you're saying the business
plan needs to be a fee only when you
don't think it's viable just to have the
enforcement side of air to say which one
I only take one or two wrong two or more
short no that is exactly you have a
non-delegable statute easy to use to
force the building record that's what
was yes so in fact I've stopped for that
and there will be a cost to yeah yeah it
also ultimately yes for imagine the
vendor if you if you if you let the fear
about inside of it Wayne you could also
they end up with more costume evidence
we didn't put that we didn't mention
that in the report Gill you can cover
that your patella burns the cat soon
yeah yeah the spring trims get around
about well you are saying it is not a
viable option is that what you're saying
the tiller interest is feeling in your
mother so you that's what I think you
could tell you probably one without the
other is not viable just to you know so
somebody fans up and asks me if
something
vacation I think they want to discuss
what I need to do is not be earning as
soon as they make habitation it's got
fear and the elements of it as soon as
the job starts to go wrong and I need to
split round the room more than once then
it's a noise if anything so it's it's
all part if you wish to if you wish to
write to me and ask me for an
explanation I can certainly do that
because I go yep you've answered the
questions on cars there are no questions
for certain ways that I've asked for
Building Control to come here for about
every six years I think I just one more
question Emma trees it's a leaf that's
painting it I can't capsule wall I've
just wanted this book why the hell the
hell if you if you feel that it
how long is possible to endorse a profit
or deficit Building Control it goes on
with the budget which you've seen and
approach rubric Adam would you expect
this to go forward have a look to be
happy to well as far as I think has been
his fine it all mixes in together with
regard to that which is statutory now
statutory means and that's what we need
to think as feeling we do need to take
on more stuff we do need to be able to
cut better with what we've got
and I think that's the important factor
we we are looking obviously when it's a
fiercely competitive market in regards
to this huge and that's the biggest
problem that we've talked about in
regards to how they're going to go
forward with building control so it's
really been a case of we may have to
look to grow but that takes a bit of
time we also need to have a multi
functional approach I look to the market
in general to see if we can recruit I
believe we went to Council to ask for a
special release with regard to have
market forces with with our wage
structure because we are not competing
at all and it's really important that
throughout the whole development
portfolio we really do need to look
seriously at deficits in right
throughout that area so it's been a case
that I believe is a valid form of income
for the council and I believe we need to
ensure that with our budgets are
directed in a way where it will actually
work and will actually my learning but
yes obviously it will take time and that
time is dependent only on recruitment
how well we get on as I say with you
we've discussed this we would look we
will look to another six or seven months
on our recruitment we've got Richard in
place which is is a big big plus I think
the council he's extremely experienced
you know has a lot of knowledge goes to
that and you know we've looked at where
we can take on young dies and may be
interested you know I think it's they
take three so there is the possibility
of taking on guys to grow your own who
have got a wee bit of now so they don't
particularly want to be working on the
tools but they do have a good idea of
building on such light and women go down
a different route when I have experience
they do know through maybe their
apprenticeships working on the science
that they do have a knowledge and then
they can bring that knowledge into
building control and and we can grow
them on so that it's really about
whether or not how long you think it
would be acceptable for a deficit you
think yeah a smaller deficit what I mean
the checks ball with it's not a big
deficit
really
see why are you coming from others I
mean just on hearing hidden template
what very minor this report and love so
it says hit live that it's overspending
for example it's due to agency starting
mmm right so just so I thought something
was better so I didn't have a look
and again this what you need to look at
in court are two figures they come out
then I will show you what they overspent
is well what I've done
says I started has taken two steps to
reduce their overspend on agencies
perfect so what is saying in the report
is that overspend is due to their 40 to
50 pounds of so reduce that expenditure
on that so this is not an official
figure but a little bit look today to
see what was the portal to is coming
down 43 so it nots your question there
is I will not tolerate it over to spend
on the budget it will have to be managed
to the started cost my patient
it's probably just worth adding just as
a final point on the city guidance we
can carry a surface or such over three
million so that's able to take account
of you know the ebbs and flows that may
occur nothing the service and
particularly yeah and particularly when
you get you have to use agency staff for
a period which we have so you know only
it's what be it's got to be
self-financing on the fear in the
element and over a rolling three period
so if we go into deficit and we would
have to take measures to bring it back
in the surplus if it goes into service
artists that we're making accumulating
too much money into it
Thank You people there's no question in
key members I did watch a very relaxed
list of asking questions the next post I
wrote down is canceled for quite I think
probably a lot of our Oscars pretty much
been coming in what absolute highs
already are so there's anything really
on connect and - I have a council of
Gooding yeah you mentioned the
development and inspection and it's very
simple straightforward it sends an email
to an inbox we set up a billion control
in the box
everything everything can go into the
everybody's not access to see that and
then we move those calls it was for
calendar okay so it says people get
frustrated about looking through and
that's not annoyed
so how would people be aware of that
because they're trying to get on the
fire and they're not getting through yes
so it'll be done
it'll be marketed on on our website
it'll be done by word of mouth Estonia
photonic every time I go on the side of
those frustrating I'll get through we
have the smart phone we can show that
the app we can when we go on site he
wants another visible book we can book
it for him on the phone and show him how
the app works at the same time so this
so we you know we respond
some people quite happy to seem to kept
through on the phone others are aren't
and I don't know I've tried to look at
what they're doing differently but
rather than waste my time with that I
just getting another
straightforward pathway through thank
you I'll be microstrip is pretty much
the same could be marketed I'm assuming
that a lot of the builders or
contractors would possibly be aware of
this can you place in that XMA said
Nationals nationally its national so so
if you're on a building site and you go
their way you are she's quite common for
those I love you can click your GPS on
your phone and it will spill Nick you to
amend you can identify where you are on
the map and it will link you to the low
there was local authority and because
we're set up on the app as soon as they
put Rochford
it just gives them a phone number if
they want to
his nicest the website they give them a
form to fill out and look inspection
that comes to his face and and in
addition to that you know there's
there's ways of sort of lining up with
planning so when we have pre-op meetings
you know there's the possibility of
Richard or a member of the team coming
down and just relaying to the developer
uptick and that the building control
service is available and and just give a
sort of quick run-through of that in
addition you know when planning letters
go out you know is possible to promote
the building control service at the same
time as that so we're looking at various
measures on the tummy more another you
know press release potential but you
know the the potential for the app could
be through a press release as well to
show that's available and if we're
sinking in builders who are in the
Southland area eruption area become
familiar with that app you know it may
spread through South Essex but at least
it's something that will be familiar to
the building some units this to use this
area so you know also go to their six
billion meters once a month to see
what's happening in the past misfits
okay thank you very much I've got cancer
Stanley next Thank You chairman my
concerns are twofold really I've heard
several speakers talk about you're
trying to prove just what for your
findings cell phone using the managers
that are using the people that you've
got already it doesn't I mean it's nice
to recruit people but ease the work
there and what have you missed when it
goes out to these approved inspectors
that you're trying to completely so have
you identified what you are competing
for and have you got sufficient scope
there to employ these things too
that you want that's more filling out I
mean the simple answer is yes the work
is there and the work has been there to
get the market share in my initial
summary of the committee report I spoke
about the post that we had found the
vehicle to recruit and what those posts
were but just to reiterate that was the
senior building control officer and the
building control officer one was a newly
created post we had an assistant
building control sir he was promoted to
the senior role and is in post one other
Boonen controller was promoted to the
senior role but has since left for
another authority so that's why we have
the senior vacancy and we have the
building control vacancy at the moment
we have recruited Richard to the team
leader role in the new structure but at
the moment we only have two full-time
posts as well as an agency staff member
who is fitting in whilst we try and
recruit to these posts so no I should
have rephrase that they're all very well
put you need a higher post but what you
really want is people on the ground so
where you are putting in a higher post
he's still trying to fill the post that
he's supposed to be doing what he's
supposed to be doing and it's not doing
that 80 to 90 basis of the post is all
very well but is that the work that is
being done is that still being worked on
from from those the working work isn't
me the work wasn't done
no there was no management in the office
so when you've got statutory days to me
ever been met so some plans were not
getting chair inspections without
getting done and if you have you go back
to today's interview market share the
question the other question is doing
there what market share we've got yes
because they each time I could inspector
text to Tommy has to give us some
initial notice so we know exactly what
we're losing you know exactly the value
of different face panels on and we've
had weeks where it's four thousand quid
a week so bearing in mind we tried to
make twenty grand a month if we're
running a seriously out of capacity
window I actually checking the plans but
nobody's going to use a service and so
they just go sleep it was better so we
just the risk is that we don't stop here
the more market share will hemorrhage
and some authorities it's down to fifty
percent so we need to be we need to be
we need to be sitting comfortably in
with the other Essex authorities which I
can toes around 70 percent some
authorities are 85 percent smaller fully
staffed and fighting about their market
share we will get the market share back
because we're actually more responsive
so if you if you open it up and you
start your extension you forgot to your
building next application we will make
sure we get somebody to that morning and
you will be able to fill out a for
campaign your favor on there and then on
that day you won't get better you won't
get that for the competition the problem
seems to me is actually what you said if
it's just getting that malaga there
aren't enough bombs on the same and we
put it bluntly because you know if we're
out during the day
macaques stopping and talking to people
because we can't do the cause was like
in round so you know we thought to have
that coma you need people to be planned
checking Pierre to be activity site
inspection yes so there is that work
available yes and then we need to fill
it well yeah we should also don't we
should we should be checking a plan when
it comes in it has a statutory of five
minutes to make a decision we should be
fitting an arts back in a fortnight not
waiting to the five we it's not
extending it for another two weeks
my neck sort of charity for K my next
question is is that if the plane hasn't
been painful for you to scrutinize where
do you go from me right so if they put
them if they put a plan in and don't pay
for it's not validated application right
so what we will do is we will do two
visits more to eat pain because the
reason for that is that once a once the
job has started with an authority can
documents so that point spending on 77th
gotta work paperwork as soon as we
before I put on that site it can't avert
approve this better yeah once on use
you're not getting a baby but you're
coming down here well we'll go out the
fee twice and then they were to pay they
can only pay you sorry you can anybody
else as well they come home with their
building work and they come in have to
pay well it's not a problem they pay up
because they won't you committed to the
service they can't go anywhere else
legally can't go to inspector wants to
work estar capsule Newport Thank You
chairman and which it's kind of
questions one of the the key issues it
was the reputation and you said about
phones not getting through yeah so have
you actually I guess you have spoken to
dawn dr about that she's in charge of
bones and yeah and is there some sort
system that's going to be put in place
to stop that happening
because we'll see us my favorite is
being put in place by me
so what was happening was that people
were sending emails to people who didn't
exist who'd left because they got the
email addresses so all the emails now go
into one building controlling box yeah
and I monitor their building controlling
box with all the messages all the phone
calls that come in go into there they're
all locked so I can see his answer if
one is not a lot and I like hate the
work from there once it's been action is
deleted from there so have you got this
in some sort of workflow system or is it
just in that mailbox it's a little it's
a billion controller box I'll pop it on
the on the email system so it's nice and
simple everybody can access them because
he was in it all staff in the in them in
the content list customer services are
all my admin team star can go into that
and remove stuff so there's more than
one person removing things from it's
only if they can actually on take it out
that speeds up the workflow so what's
happening this is going into people's
individual email accounts and you can't
see what they've actually you can't see
it come in and that was what was
happening so people were sending stuff
drawings and things to people who didn't
exist and then saying that you mentioned
earlier is that app available to your
competition the approved no there's only
two for anybody so you're not in
competition what they may have an app
with it yeah I'm sure that they could
buy that kind of service but this is so
because the builders I've often spoken
to a corporate technophobes and you know
a lot of them struggle to send an email
from what obviously yes and so it's
probably is a good thing if it's
standard if they're working in different
areas one app yes or that could be
helpful as a local authority I suppose
in that that's the good thing
we're actually using the one that's
being used in Southend and and I believe
beyond in Cass appointment oh it is
I don't we deliver the service how
people wanted to live it I mean if
they've got builders who don't use a
phone and they come into the office this
means worse if they want to you know
most people use a phone if they can't
get through for any reason they look
kind of busy on another table we go I
mean we can you know it's on as long as
as long as we're keeping up with the
work and seeing what they're doing the
kind of stages we want to it's not
essential to see absolutely everything
and we'll be in contact all the time
some people you know as long as they're
given the right guidance on the politics
so just building on this reputation
ideally like do I say the clients do
they have an expectation is that they
will be responded to within X amount of
time you all endeavor to do a site visit
that it's amount of time or is that
something that you on the a pit and
expectation is that if you phone before
ten o'clock the same day we if we
consider it something that we want to
say everything in mind you could ask for
something we don't need to see so we'll
always go back to people if we think
that we need to see at a later stage or
they need to develop the work a bit more
before we go so I think that's pretty
good
I think if you've found anybody and try
and get a visit the same thing up to ten
o'clock availing what we've got to all
those parts to their science I think
that's a pretty good and what the
expectation is is that we give an
estimate or visit that we intending to
do to expectation is so it's not our
responsibility to comply with the
building regulations or make sure that
the visits are done is the owner and the
builders so if they fail to call a
signal they don't contact us that they
have to take responsibility and I'm in
the works thing but we the whole point
is to make it as accessible as possible
well so has a local authority do do you
beat the competitor if you like yes and
that they don't do same Davises is the
issue with that approvement that's why
we particularly we also do partnerships
with other authorities where they check
the plans and we did the local
inspections and they can they stick with
the same partner so there's various
other schemes within there may be sale
encourage members to have a look at the
NABC website and see what we've set out
for nationally and which legally clearly
buy into and as we you know hopefully
get to a full running efficient service
you know there's there's then
possibilities that which we look at with
our mobile authorities about how we
function you know as a collective
particularly you know with something and
others to improve that service you know
that we provide there is Aneta Building
Control performance indicators
if he needs to Richard your song by this
act but you're going to get people
coming malach with all the applications
coming a lot quicker to you isn't that a
bit of a double-edged sword because you
haven't got the start to look at them
leave the apps for the inspection yeah
so if you've got a lot coming in through
from that yes but then your scientist
you have enough stuff that's right well
I'm not having that one that of course
you're having more less well you'd be
done it doesn't again we what we do is
we manage the calls so we get more calls
that we can do so what we'll do is say
you've got 25 calls and we can only do
15 then we'll look at them and assess
them and decide which ones needs to be
prioritized so correctly but that's the
top of the list contact those other
people see if they think they need that
visit that day move it on and then if
it's a visit that is really not
essential saying for installation or
something like that and they've got
people waiting remember made over here
and it's holding them up then once they
don't want can you take a photograph of
the fluid station and email it to me so
your screed is can carry onto the floor
insulation so will feel those calls will
manage them we manage the expectation of
the Builder so doesn't get held up it's
all about keeping the building work
going because from a business point of
view the faster they go get through the
jobs the more the more jobs I get coming
through my door for the more think Oh
again so there's no need anybody thinks
about hobby builders are up it's a
business it's gonna work because you're
gonna slow down your income stream the
key element is that risk assessment and
prioritizing those jobs that definitely
need an inspection literature said those
that don't so we have people telling us
where the work is and we have to decide
what we need to see to make sure that
complies at the end so we can't see
every single element of it and some
people will tell us all sorts of things
that they want to be looked at and
sometimes people and just a very short
spear advice and that can be given over
the phone and while they're spending
time to visit all right thank you know
you mentioned getting more access mobile
access to the planning system
documentation oh and we've got a nice
ICT improvements coming in have you got
sort of an idea how you're going to go
with that and rough outline of the sort
of business case for it yeah my my my
feeling about it is isn't we should do
whatever makes us more productive
bearing in mind the time resources that
we've got and there are various systems
which link to but they think yet to be
developed as stage where we can have
access to all the information we need
clearly so if you if you take for
example anyone
touring need if you reduce it to tablet
size the productivity issue try to
retrieve that resolve the information
from it the quality of light on the site
they do gender parity what abilities it
doesn't let me lend yourself to it what
does lend itself to it is more of the
record-keeping and inspection arts so
where you might have popped out their
news
take out things and speed up the the
recruiting of visits because if you work
out five minutes of visit in terms of
doing the record-keeping and life is
this forty minutes so if you can if you
can reduce that and then it also means
that other people can view those records
so if you don't come back to the office
because it's more you take a run back to
your home base then if that you're not
coming in the following day you've got
paper with you know you can see the
visits that you've made all that you pay
but if you make that electronic you can
actually you can actually see that but
the problem we've got is that the the
size of the information if I was in the
drawings and the volume of drawings that
you need for quite complex building
doesn't lend itself to small device so
we will leave the yet to explore battle
anything you can put it on but income
you come the speed of looking at a
drawing and scanning over it with the
experience is much quicker as website so
it's really a Productivity issue so in
selecting any changes we've got to
maintain the productivity because if
otherwise we'll be you know doing more
doing less in the world thank you very
much thank you members there are a
couple of recommendations redesign
training but we'll need to be
apprentices and graduate trainees and
that a package of retention and
recruitment is essential for there to be
any possibility in recruiting experience
I don't think we know today it confuses
me a little bit why we're being asked to
know them yeah I think it's just it I
suppose it was part of acknowledgment
that we we may not have to go down that
route but there's the potential that we
know we may have to if we cannot recruit
through the process that we want to to
get qualified members of staff and
that's in the senior and the control
officer role so there is a possibility
that we may have to look at recruitment
process but going through training
recruitment which has additional
potential budget implications I think it
was just highlighting how long does the
recruitment being advertised has been
advertised and if we're not getting that
recruitment that you specifically want
whether it be military wise or whatever
where do you see it I mean I don't know
how long it's been going on for but if
it's been going on for several months
then the the where do you find where to
go I suppose that's why and it was
agreed at full council that there's
potential to look at market supplements
to recruit to hard to recruit posts if
you have a business case and part of
that business case
is demonstrating that you have tried to
recruit to that post a number of times
and we have for that and since I've been
in post which was 31st of October last
year we have tried to recruit to these
posts since the restructure of it was
put in place which was the first of May
so we have attempted since the 1st of
May to recruit to these posts and have
been unsuccessful with every form of
trade magazine website etc but we've
also looked at the benchmarking of the
posts and they they are they were and
and the restructure has assisted that
but they are still below the level of
equivalent posts neighboring authorities
that we are competing with where do you
where do you follow when you find
yourself to go so we will be putting a
business case together for a market
supplement for these posts and if that
is agreed then we hope that that will
make us competitive with our neighboring
authorities and be able to recruit to
these posts so that is the next stage
and hopefully when we come back to next
we'll be able to say that we were
successful with that process
yes not question about the ugh I think
it's a I think recommendation to
something we probably don't mean to do
or be uncomfortable doing I think it's
virtually saying that we were it was we
it doesn't say birth to my mom time if
it was out virtually recommending the
budget if they related by the opening of
it and I think it says it in the report
anyway so what the family notes really
we're noting the problems around
recruitment and I think this was
originally cubed coming back in February
which I think is too soon so
just talking obviously tune we chop see
is in the next music it can be a
recommendation you do that [ __ ] it
before that is probably gonna be too
soon
I think so by the February of definite
because by the time that we've looked at
the business case in place then the next
review committee would be writing the
report in January so we've only got
December and you know it just doesn't
give opportunity to even have recruited
to those post so there's probably
wouldn't be much more to a report than
we've actually reported at this session
today to take it off about one day we
all typically suggest do somewhere
suggested would you be M mind about even
doing like that way
[Music]
yeah so so the report looks at the
outline of enforcement powers available
to the authority there's a particular
emphasis I think that came out of a
previous meeting in relation to to a
board adverts and what the powers are
available to the authority as much of
District Council and what's available to
the authority in in conjunction with the
Highways Authority to deal with these
issues in addition I think there was
reference made to the projects that took
place earlier in the year against
unauthorized other advertisements and
what actions have taken place and and
what potential future actions could take
place if if it was possible to do this
in the future the report sort of
outlines the the acts and the process of
prosecution that's available to the
authority in relation to adverts and a
board and and it's noted it's a slightly
different process that the Highways
Authority have available to them when
they take action but there's has a
slightly different emphasis on on why
they would be
removing these adverts compared to the
local authority would have available
it's noted in the report that this level
of Tolerance in relation to a boards
that Essex highways have taken and
there's guidance in relation to that
toleration and that's detailed in the
report as such as what various
businesses can put on the public highway
as long as they adhere to a number of
conditions of the Highways Authority so
in relation to the report as a whole it
kind of concludes that I suppose with
with resources that are available to our
enforcement team that they are
attempting to work with their colleagues
in highways Essex to remove as many
efforts as they can as possible where it
complies with the highway authorities
regulations on under their arts and
where we can take action in relation to
how rot should as a local authority can
in relation to to adverts but there's
only a certain I suppose that there is a
balance to be made between the other
functions and actions that our
enforcement team have to take with the
size of the enforcement team that we
have and have to balance dealing with
enforcement of availables and
unauthorized adverts in relation to
other enforcement action in relation to
planning applications that have taken
place and
and dealing with our at the same time
with the resource that we have available
and I think that's sort of where where I
probably conclude at this point and take
questions I wouldn't usually start by
asking personal waste employment myself
but on this occasion in this case no I
think for me as a member of the public
remember so I'm a member of rainy Town
Council as well which I have declared
the I think one of the biggest
challenges in this area on this topic is
the perception and very often that's the
case when it comes to things like crime
and everything else you know figures
might be no but it's the perception and
nothing the issue here is the perception
that no enforcement isn't being taken
seriously and the force of the
perception is that the enforcement team
is significantly below the numbers it
should be in order to deal with the
amount of issues there are it's
different it's difficult to tackle a
perception issue I appreciate that but I
mean I mean as far as resources are
concerned yes the perception might be
correct that you know it you know
unfortunately is a difficult function in
planning and it's it's it's readily
contacted it's it's it's one that is the
resources available at different
authorities particularly in South Essex
you know available to them is
is markedly different and we only have
you know two officers available to carry
out that function which does restrict us
when you think of the other roles and
functions that have to be taken with an
enforcement team and that's preparing
for public inquiries hearings the other
side of public interest as far as
enforcement is concerned related to two
matters that are are different to the
enforcement of adverts so as I said sort
of previously it is that balance that
you have to take particularly when you
only have a very small team to carry out
that function if we did have additional
resource and we have tested additional
resource because we did have a bit of
funding available to help the
enforcement team clear cases and
compliance and we had that during August
and and that did provide some additional
scope and some of those factors that may
have not been able to address being
addressed previously by the enforcement
team was able to be enforced and it did
make a significant difference to the
team having that additional resource
even though it was a part-time resource
it did allow that function to to operate
better and address other issues that may
have not been enough to address
previously and that could relate to you
know the enforcement of adverts a boards
etc and liaison without colleagues Essex
to to carry out some of those functions
that Essex are running into but have
agreed that we can do for them on
occasion so yes that that additional
resource always helps but there's no
there's no permanent funding for that
additional resource we've tested it did
work very well but unfortunately at the
moment there's not a growth item but do
you think allow it's that perception
that this department is significantly
understaffed and you know seemingly
unable to cope
with the amount of enforcement cases
there are that this issue will only get
worse because I think it seems that from
the public's opinion is it if they want
to put up an advert that you know would
be subject to an enforcement order it's
not gonna be done with suppose it's
prioritize okay there is a perception we
don't we don't know that that's how
everybody thinks it's just a perception
and if we are notified the business and
puts up an unauthorized ad the case is
opened and it gets investigated and it
follows that due process but what's
happened in the past is that the report
of those authorized and onions rice dad
first has been a bit and pop and not a
consistent approach has been taken so
when we're going out to investigate that
particular breach that's been reported
to us the first thing that we're
confronted these were what about that
business over there and and that one
this hasn't been reported to us so we
haven't got as Matthew said we haven't
got the resources to pick up do a you
know complete sweep and that's what the
project was for but if something is
reporting to us it is a cases opened and
it is investigated now it may not be
resolved as quickly as to complain them
already to a council or any other parish
council may wish us to resolve that in
the time
you know they think he's adequate but we
as Matthew says we've got to direct our
resources to the most serious breaches
and that's where the matter of perhaps
being under visa Worcester at this
particular time becomes a real issue for
us but I mean what we've got to remember
is that we've been you know as only sort
of turned a half years ago that we went
through a redesign that was agreed and a
post was deleted from the Enforcement
Team as a result of the redesign so we
are where we are - Kate's fingers
counselor - but yes do your officers
have a list of approved and unapproved
signage yes we would we would we would
have well we'd have a list of if that
somebody's applied correctly consent and
gone through the advert consent
application process then that would be
on a database if we've had a report of
an advert that the complainant considers
is unauthorised then we'd have a record
of that we don't have a database if all
unauthorized at first in the district
and that was the purpose of the project
that we rebooted it a year ago but you
have a list of approved banners posters
where they've applied for consent but
the problem is when you're approved
sighs now especially now you wouldn't
know down the Ashington Road on the
corner of raised learning we have
railings on the side and a road which
they just sort of appear hmm no no it's
the leash no well then why is Essex
can't be canceled got one down there
right well then you've got right okay so
when I say
the more improved they haven't got
advert consent but they may not need
advert ransom because you've got
something in the advert regulations that
Alain enables at some efforts to be
displayed under what's called a deemed
consent I've referred to it it's been
referred to in the port there's 16
different classes in the advert
regulations that enable certain adverts
to be displayed without obtaining an
vote consent so we wouldn't have a
record of those they would just need to
be assessed as to whether or not they
need this is fine you know having an
approved sign here 100% precise yeah
it's a pretty it's when are the people's
things for himself
there were there's a sign on their
railings that's a fantastic place to
advertise what I will get is a 25 foot
sign tied up and we'll tighten tie back
to me think yes then that happens
there's another thing that happens
especially deadly Ashington Road if you
all get and then covered in billboards
advertising stickers of the same thing
parked in the lay-by and that will be
there for two or three weeks is that
approved or not approved right well then
that's on the highway okay so that's a
matter for the Highway Authority that's
not for us well you know I reported this
a million times to hard ways of for me
and it's they just passed about the one
there it's not on its parking it's this
that the other
yeah well I mean a vehicle people can be
parked in the lane boy okay it's a bit
like advert if you think about an advert
on the bus okay remind practice of that
vehicle ways to transport people from A
to B okay so any adver on a bus is fine
that's got Dean concern if vehicles
being parked in a [ __ ]
specifically to display the advert then
that's different okay and that would
mean
okay because it's got no danger to
consent but because it's on the highway
it's a matter for the Highway Authority
now the Highway Authority I've spoken to
them recently the highway authority have
said that if something is reported to
them as an obstruction on the highway on
their online reporting they've got
highway inspectors that will go out and
make an assessment but Essex County
Council under the same resource
constraints is what we are so they will
have to prioritize as to then criteria
is easy a highway safety issue yeah not
that it's affecting immunity or you just
don't like it but it's there so then
they've got different criteria and
filter that they're going when they go
out to check something that they're
looking at and again they would have to
prioritize it's not causing obstruction
it's Highway Safety that's what they're
looking at so if it says try distracting
drivers which it could well be because
if you want to be focused on driving
down the road and then you're looking at
what the adverts sign than that probably
and what sidelines or anything to go on
we've established that's not really your
read no cancer Cooper was that that
answer because you know this is just a
can of worms out there everybody you
know to put signs up and hope for the
best that they don't get caught because
I can't see what's the deterrent is yeah
I mean on you know on occasion if if we
were out you know we're in that area
then it is a highways issues but as I
said in the report we're in the area and
we've got the time we will sniff those
banners down or a brace liner we've done
it but they're getting quite clever and
of course yeah and they're making bigger
and really rigid card I can't get into
my car so you know so it really we have
to then rely more on the highway
authority and we report we report
ourselves on lines that my way Authority
and we peel because it's quite a a
useful tool that they've got you can
actually pin on the map exactly where
the illness on counselors have actually
used as the system yourselves one more
question sorry is there a financial
penalty for putting up the posters and
I'm not sure what the Highway Authority
will do but we can we can take action
although we mean go along and take the
posters down and the bandits down we're
sort of doing it under the highway
authorities legislation we can't enforce
under the authority of legislation we
can only enforce under the Turner
Country Planning Act where we can find a
lot more work going into this really
doesn't mean yeah councillor Newport
surprised you're still working and
office stress with so Matthew you said
that the district dues
some work and Essex County Council under
there
well this this was what Yvonne was just
hinting at though it's a highway
function in collaboration with them or
assisting them where we can to remove
some of the signage that you know
wouldn't comply with that safety element
then if we are in the suttas vicinity if
we are in the zone where it's taking
place and we are able to remove it then
you know we can and will try to do that
so so without trying to anger anyone in
the room but is there is there any scope
for that type of work
to be delegated to parish councils well
I mean this is something that has been
sort of discussed I mean it would have
to do need you know we need to think it
through and the correct delegating
procedures would have to you know to
have to go through the correct
procedures to actually dedicate that
authority but it would only be the
removal at the anthers norm you know
once the decisions been made that it's
unlawful or this you know it's illegal
then perhaps we could look to parish and
tell councils - I guess yeah it would be
a function of sweeping things up as it
were you know it the authority and
decision would still need to lie with
Essex County Council but who they deemed
to then carry out the action could be
another body
I guess because what we really want to
do is burden Town Council's and parish
councils with having to make the
decision as to whether or not that
advert is a League
because of the the advert regulations
she wouldn't be party to some of the
information that the local authority
held to be able to make their decision
on that basis so we've had been Richard
earlier in Building Control he's going
out or he's not going out and he's
getting photos sending so sua says yeah
well you're just using technology to to
the benefit of the council to cut down
on his travel in time so it risk
yeah so you could you could have a
similar thing for this where photographs
are sent you can assess from the photo
and then delegate along I guess that's
something would have to be explored with
Essex County Council but potentially
that is an approach that could be taken
if it allows enough information and
evidence to make that decision I guess
over and above what the authority would
make currently I mean we've got to be
careful of is insurance you know on
uncovered because I can you know I'm a
council officer so if I'm if I'm injured
or something happens to me while I want
to take that work then I'm covered but
we need to look at you know good parish
counselors or body works under the
parish council Town Council would there
be insurance implications I mean it
really needs to be thought through is it
is say an idea that's been discussed you
know and and also that I think you know
we've got an agreement with county that
we take them down for County it's a bit
of an informal agreement but you know I
think if we're going to then as a local
planning authority then delegating
you know to parish counts parish and
town councils from highways legislation
I think that that really needs to be
checked the legally flawed legally I
suppose it's a concept okay looked at
yeah absolutely it could be looked at
there's you know um cancer hood ways
that we don't really have an issue in
their their parish or it could be
localized in different parishes you know
war with parish might not have that
problem so that's why I was just asking
is it a possibility and I'm mostly yeah
it doesn't have to be a blanket
delegation every of parish if there's
not issues in some parishes then it may
be just an arrangement between you know
certain parishes or town council with
Essex but as if on state would have to
check the legalities of it and that
delegation and the decision making and
and then yeah that there are the
insurance implications for those who are
then deemed to you know to have the
authority then to remove those items
thank you yeah I mean it's just an
observation it seems it's quite a lot of
similarities between this and
frightening in respect that regards
flight if in there's quite an expensive
cost to go and get someone prosecuted
for doing it and is a disincentive for
the council to sue it on a cost basis
although the benefit is that if you do
get someone prosecuted it deters people
from doing it in the particular area
yeah and the other aspect is that it
might be localized to particular areas
and the other thing is that one instant
tends to mean that it multiplies one if
you like we fly to get one in flight if
it's not dealt with it multiplies
because you get more
people using the same sigh and a similar
thing with this it would seem get one
over tonight
one illegal just when someone is allowed
to get away of it for a period of time
tends to encourage others others to
follow suit
so is there is there anything that we
can learn from the positive in the issue
that could be used in relation to how we
deal with this matter
yeah I me more I mean fly-tipping isn't
my department and however I mean we we
do have you know quite strong powers
under Turner Country Planning Act to
deal with illegal and - yeah we if we
identify we can identify who the
advertiser it is then in theory if we
had the resources we as a local planning
authority we have to give them notice
that they're displaying emotion that's
labeling we have to give them second
raise to remove the effort if they don't
remove the answer then in theory we can
prosecute them but all we can say to
them we'll go in and remove the advert
ourselves but that's where the resource
at element comes into because you know I
haven't bought the resources on my team
for somebody to sit down and research
you that you know where to send that to
because a lot of the time advertisers
would just have the name of the company
and the telephone number bar to
correctly serve that letter that formal
notice I need to know I've got to serve
it on all interested parties so that
sometimes can be the advertising company
the advertise the business that's been
advertised and then potentially Galang
so I've got to do that research I've got
to send that letter I've then got so for
it to be an effective process I've then
got to diary seven days time to go back
and check whether adverse been removed
or not it's a very simple process but as
Matthew indicated earlier we've got
limited resources and we've got some
real serious breaches occurring in them
in the district that I've got to Porat
eyes it was all disease to something
that might be another similarity here is
if someone is prosecuted and find that
money does not come back to the council
on Thursday night in the same way we
flaunt it as well any in the same way
that they dealt with some possibly can
find appliances with the money that they
are fine on that account
yeah so you're spending money on
something that you do not get something
back yes there is an option because
because Delilah and along the rise the
advert is a criminal offence then we can
at the time that we go to call we can
actually apply for a confiscation order
under the proceeds of Crime Act okay so
basically that will enable us to recover
all of all the financial benefit that
that advertiser has achieved from
displaying that advert if we say you
know it could be proven and with we can
access we have to use a financial
investigator which we haven't got the
authority but we potentially got access
to somebody transferred they would then
delve into the advertisers financial
records and if we can demonstrate that
that advertised by denying that
advertisement that company is generating
so an additional 10,000 pounds worth of
business by displaying that ad firm then
in theory we can apply for a
confiscation to get that 10,000 pound we
don't get all of it we get a percentage
of it but there is an opportunity for it
to be so have you ever exercised
Chancellor Stanley Thank You general
just two things that come to mind the
first one is it's a bonds that are on
the pavements are in the way of the
Destry ins and with the council and the
highways essays can chasm surely you can
have a budget between you that would
actually empower those someone's to be
removed as for the signs that are on
radians and that sort of thing I would
think that if they're inside there's not
much you could do about it
inside the property inside that the
property rather than as solid as if
they're air so I don't become on the
highway and if they're inside they're in
public land and although you've got
jurisdiction on to the sides we'll
really know that the my net
Phegley where the council had several
attempts at reducing the sign it's still
there and they've been there for years
so it's not those signs I don't think
that the public especially rightly is
concerned it's the signs though the
summons that read in the highway and and
because of if the council was to make
just one just one attempt and take that
person whoever it may be
it's a prosecution it would then give
others oops
perhaps we shouldn't be doing that it
only needs one effort one major effort
to do that and there that will that will
then give everybody else maybe I
shouldn't be doing there on the outside
all the pain
and though inside my property inside the
surrounding area of their property we
already know that from the 10 counsel
they could do it within their own /
anything else that's not so when it
becomes on the highway we need to do
something about that suggestion alone
might get they suggested I'm making and
I don't know how how whether you need
planning if you are going to put up a a
protective sheet that has a sign on it
if you're renovating a shop and you put
protective sheet up for safety purposes
you have a sign might be legitimate
patrons if it's advertising the
development or the company that's doing
that development
then there are certain deemed consent
that you can have the holdings
advertising purely because it's a safe
at Sam's restaurant for example yeah
that's got a branch down the road but
fat Sam's all were also going to take
over this this other unit and it's being
refurbed at the moment this Holdings up
and there's a sign on building saying
coming soon fat sounds no restaurant the
best banking town then they can do that
because because they've got deemed
consent under the advert breaks for
adverts on hold jeans there's a criteria
that they have to make no you have to
apply for that so no I know yeah but um
yeah I mean if I take your point where
the a vault you're right yeah if it's
therefore the call they've got Dean
consent again is criteria that needs to
be met they can only have up to a
certain area of adverb but it is quite
liberal okay because for corporate
breaks also applies to so for example
petrol stations and if you think about
the you know the adverts you have in
petrol stations it's quite a liberal so
eyeballs on a personal for call is bad
so as long as it's within therefore I
think they can do a lot under their dink
when you use in the highway my boy
you're you're correct in theory they
would need consent but from highway
authority yet but what the Highways
Authority is done yeah they've been
produced this document in 2013 I don't
know members if obscene yourself no okay
so basically this is SS countess policy
on on a board okay now what it's saying
is is that they'll tolerate one a board
on the highway providing that there's a
criteria here providing that there's
still an unobstructed Sun for
pedestrians to pass you might be asking
is that one I all from every premises or
is that just one or equal in the whole
strip yeah why not you can kill for you
yeah you can play Dungeons fan yeah but
it does go on to say in the policy if
there becomes a proliferation of a
boards you know then maybe they might
review the situation so there's you know
then there's a bit more scope for
businesses now to have an ad board on my
way and this is you know when we
sometimes get with
it's coming through and I know that in
baby town council you know they say
contact artists and about particular
businesses I mean we if they are
obstructing the highway because you know
somebody with a mobility scooter or a
doggie buggy or visual impairment is
finding it difficult then we will go out
there and ask them to move it now most
of the time they're quite compliant they
they moved it back and it's not been a
problem but on occasion we do get
certain businesses that don't do what we
ask them to do
so that's impulse back to the highway
authority because it's their legislation
but we can do it again anyway so do you
know as this Mystics that our issue in
though do Essex issue that to all
businesses or is it just a document that
sounds like I'm not aware yeah I presume
that it just sits on their website so so
it's unlikely the businesses are gonna
be proactive in seeking mister point
Thank You chairman yeah thanks very much
things quite illuminating so far across
that there are different areas have
problems of different sorts of
advertising or I would suggest I think
that if you come to whole bridge I don't
think there's a problem with eyeballs at
all I would hesitate ladies I don't want
to report this but there is one
internally the nature side which I'm
well aware is not being applied for but
when I suppose people no one even knows
this there's no not a problem
I told where as I mentioned ran a
conservation era made between greatly it
might good
it may be a problem so I think so it's
very awkwardly this comes across to what
you were saying about well that business
is hasn't being force that one has but
they might be in different areas soccer
done understand the point not from my
point of view from the board I represent
he doesn't seem to be problem but I
think in certain areas of convening I
think it comes back to Pam's a blip on
caster Stanley was saying that maybe it
could be worthwhile prosecuting some
people in some areas because it there's
a specific problem there so you could be
a vault in radio or illuminating signs
in Raley the one I would pick out to a
knife spoke much about before but not
for some years is fairways diner and the
land there opposite the Rayleigh Club
where there is a place over a lot of
silence now probably one has planning
personal didn't do a couple of years ago
not bothered reporting it seems but
they're still there mmm-hmm and
presumably that goes back to what we
were saying different advertisers
probably one landowner but lots of
different businesses being advertised
tomorrow mine a prosecution there would
be worth one liters a very what he's
regarded by many people's one of the
only areas already get complaints about
a massive advertising about a visual
amenity it does
Annie's distraction when you drive near
onra they have interesting accidents
around the area whether or not they're
caused by the efforts I do not know but
there's a chunk there's a quite complex
Junction they're going to the golf club
keep left side ski right lines partially
concealed entrances of roads and then
you've got all these signs down the road
so I'm going on public : or more I don't
know
well the ones that are on the grass
verge are yes and then there's some
that's melted off before the faint
selves I mean I've been on the team
since 2008 and I know the counselors
have been very vocal about the adverts
at at fair worries but at least you know
since
as the night so I I would imagine the
unfortunately although not all but some
could actually smell not we won't be
able to take any position against them
the question was is there a time is
handing exam probably on the adverts as
well yeah there is ten years so ten
years so again that would that would
even be more costly than trying to
establish show them their being there
and try to mean I mean obviously what I
have to weigh up is you know we look at
the council's business plan and it's all
about doing what our community members
of their community want us to do and
we've don't get a lot of complaints
about adverts it was my next question
hmm all completely different counselors
or other I it frustrates me because yeah
I I agree adverts do affect the amenity
of the district and when we have had a
blitz in the district along the main
classified rides which tend to be the
the preferred areas of some of the
advertisers you know because it's on the
main drag and then they're going to get
the most sort of you know exposure when
we've gone down there in the past and
done them you know spent the morning
clearing our it's quite refreshing to
actually drive down there and see that
the area cleared
but it incrementally they come back home
at the time but you know we it's not
something that really
Publica constantly on find to us they've
bear concerns or other matters and
planning yes we've just just two more
things with regard to that just a bit
more in depth on this so where it comes
in a point when you talk about highway
safety yeah so but freaks big issue for
highway safety for highways does it have
to do a highway name or not so for
instance in there was the one which was
almond ring how would you know you dealt
with Avaya highways it was moved it was
anyone advertising it fairways died none
of those we'd have to get Paul with his
flag driver to move in problem you can
do that but he still I find it still
distracting he says you come around the
bend there's a sign is that it's not my
always known as a farmer's field is that
vision is is that highways issue or not
even though I think you believe the
legislature as legislation talks about
advertisements on highway so that's
where their power come see yeah we would
for example if if fairways diner with
the trailing field if they come to us
with an ad for an application for
enfoque assent for them stay there we
would consult my ways and then hallways
with simple actually we consider it's
distracting to road users that would be
a reason for use for us refused the
application but and then you know so so
if we're looking at that from a pure
planning enforcement matter we would
need to write to fairways the land the
farm owners landowner giving them seven
days to remove Redford quite simple
process as I said but it's
you know while I'm asking if while I'm
doing that or my off bottom offices well
they got one well one of the other
officers doing that we're not dealing
with other matters that unfortunately
demand not just to the doctor down with
we've gone from what I guess the new
people said about other agencies maybe
helping you such as parish councils I
understand that the highway rangers now
may now be under slightly more control
from the district council our ranges are
on the road around the road network
doing other work would it be possible to
give them if they are signs which
shouldn't be there within their area
their work and the powers to remove them
they were the officers of the council
where they sit before we could explore
they issue highways at low again it's
something that we could explore the
answers would take the advance then yes
if it's reported that would be there
anything yeah sorry they are inspected
so we'll just wait to see what happens
it could be more interesting if they
come under around eventually do they've
got to be probably three or four years
okay just for them question or suppose
he's some it's just they
so really it's what we're getting to
another knife has the woman was coming
on this as well is it's a question of
whether all we as members wish to devote
more resources to to this in in effect
another officer perhaps or whether we're
content to see the visual amenity of the
district deteriorate I suppose so it's
up to us what we want believe we've
taken away and obviously you've said
so should we put it on so that I guess I
do you remember when they were
possession just you know just reply we
know is a report that does he look like
so as far as that's concerned that will
be down to yourselves as members to
support but within the budget and we we
understand we will understand that there
are budget priorities we we would like
to think that that some of the
priorities within development are
greater priorities than elsewhere but we
know that there are probably greater
priorities that needs to be looked at
and there's always has to be concessions
made as we're going along but at the end
of the day is down to members ultimately
to think they'll hang on a second we
want to see a nice tiny aspect within
with our district and if it means that
we can give a greater resource to our
enforcement team which actually has you
know their the impact it would have on
other items I think you know we've
looked at the surface we're scratching
the surface here with a boards and
advertising there are far more other
very very difficult items of enforcement
that really do need to get support so
you know I would like you know members
to actually look at supporting the
concept behind that what we've looked at
fair enough is a boards and advertising
and the things that as you say the
visual and the communities that are
going on and how it really the
perception around okay no one can care
about what's going on because now nobody
seems to be doing anything we understand
that and we we've talked at length with
regard to how we want to go about this
that's why within this report is it's
given the opportunity for members to
look at it and say hang on a second
there is an issue in what we do need to
support enforcement but that's down to
you think I think we're going to go
they're happy just add to that obviously
in the report it's it's just a ballpark
figure for a cost for a period of time
for an officer the on costs and what
finance would be could be different from
what officer the you'd have if it was a
planning office or if it was a officer
who was carrying out compliance but not
necessarily planning officers so there's
different costs involved in the level of
resource just just to put out there and
and that was just kind of a figure that
was taken into account if you look at
the main point to to look at a six-month
period of review so say something on
that please just say it was just the
point on the illuminated signs I did try
make but Matt perhaps it's not necessary
reform district when you need because I
don't see any way in help which cares
about new nature signs we don't have a
conservation area for a start some
perhaps rating they do maybe watch they
may be great than they do bar think it
could be more targeted to conservation
areas maybe if that's where the issue is
nothing else but it could be more
targeted as well counselor mrs. Roy yeah
if they're just two people in your team
so what you're saying is me and one
other so yes so but you don't just do
with billboards you do a fourth minute
if the whole plan suppose all sort of
spread yeah yeah they tell you so yeah I
mean that's the thing that's kind of
what sort of alluding to the start
there's obviously there's used the
visual effect of the immunity and and
that's something that members the public
see and and the perception that the
chair was talking about but there's a
lot of other functions that the
enforcement team carry out and you know
significant breaches of planning which
Yvonne spoke about earlier during during
the committee so you know it's at the
moment you know that the priority and
and what planning should be doing is
making those decisions about what the
priorities are with the resource in the
public interest and I guess you know
that's the balance that's not to be
taken between
these serious breaches and the effect on
the visual amenity and and how we
balance that out and I guess that's you
know with with addition results and I
guess that's what was able to be carried
out because we were able to still carry
out the the work in relation to serious
breaches but we're also to have a
compliance officer say for instance who
was able to go up and then check what's
happening potentially agree remembers
eight boards and other matters that
doesn't need to be dealt with by a
planning officer in in the last year how
many would you say that you've actually
that you've actually gone working
prosecuting I mean okay so we knew what
happens to happen is is that we
threatened with prosecution and then it
gets to the point where we cite them
right with passing it to our legal
department to prosecute to for them to
escape prosecution proceedings and then
all the sudden we get compliance right
so we hang on ago you quit all that talk
yes and that moment yeah and then they
do it the eleventh hour they'll comply
no oh yeah that's that's been restoring
so it's quite resource intensive at that
time when they you know still have the
opportunity to yes I'm sorry thank you
yeah I mean so you know looking at what
we was talking about earlier about the
proceeds of Crime Act
we don't actually you know we could
potentially go after somebody try to
make an example of it and with it in
mind that if we get to call we're going
to apply this confiscation order with
the view of maybe getting some money
back and then at the eleventh hour
we do what we do I'm conscious of the
time I do think we have competition it's
a quite a degree just if I can just push
by asking it just a very kind of
questions do you know the average cost
of prosecution and I don't know no no I
can I can speak to our legal team and
like that was just a retailer and
counselor mrs. hoy point what you're
actually saying is you've not made any
prosecutions you know we've not had to
yes you've not had to make any
prosecutions and we've never actually
pursued anybody as you mentioned earlier
about how we can get money back by
firing cease of crime and president over
that either man okay sorry chairman if
we get an answer of how many we put in
action for prosecution which have them
complied this year I think possibly I
think did you have an average time of
how long that takes
the procedure just so the members have a
better idea from start one one
particular restaurant in really high
street they put up a board put up a sign
across the shop it was unlisted building
it was illuminated and we probably spend
about six to eight months going round
and round and is that an average time
yeah yeah thank you lastly
got the point do you work with the order
alongside or family names with the
licensing
committees it seems to me that a lot of
the problems are with regards to
licensed premises and I'm intrigued that
these premises are the ones that put the
adverts out why is that not being
followed up with regards to last EP the
complaint being made about a licensed
premises use of advertising surely that
well we do work with licensing we happen
I mean I don't know I don't know the
licensing legislation I don't know the
the licensing legislation requires them
to have consent for their advert before
their issues in life because not for
their issue persons could could there
not be a restriction I suppose but
potentially it is it's III don't have
any I don't have knowledge of that but
whether yeah whether there is the
ability to to put in restrictions I
don't know but perhaps there is but we
don't have knowledge of that to two
parts coming we need to be thority we're
always trying to convey the fact that
we're recently and we're not although
they they're doing something that they
need consent for and a display of an
unauthorized advert is legal we have to
be careful that we're not hindering
business so you know it it's a balancing
act for example yeah if I can just
explaining if we've got an ad for over
of business premises that isn't
authorized we might allow them to retain
that advert while they're applying for
consent another situation where it's not
a business it's not on a business
premises we would if they wanted to
apply for consent we'd insist that they
removed that effort while they sought
that consent but if it was actually on
the business premises we may because of
obviously not wanting to him
like then we may allow them to is it
really is it quick questions I think on
the back of what you've just said in
relation to licensing how this fits in
with an example we might worry very will
be if someone wants to have a licensed
premises that's in semi residential area
or and and the licensing made akai
restrictive because of the surroundings
now if someone's got a license for
coming out whether it's a bar or
something like that if they then
suddenly start putting it bright
illuminated signs and stuff like that
that would potentially breach their
licensing arrangements with the council
as well as on the Planning sadhaks I
think there is that crossover
potentially in in some areas I mean we
get notified when a nice and seen
application comes in we get notified so
it's sent through to us so I think of my
question and are you or will you perhaps
looking with me to say we we are notify
the licensing application is made it's
sent through to us and if we do have any
concerns and we get an opportunity to be
able to so find it if a complaint is
made to you about a licensed premises
that is perhaps blatantly advertisement
so they shouldn't be yeah are you
liaison with the license in the people
have granted that license and telling
them that they are preaching there and
we're not at the present moment we would
just deal with that as a case may be
they're threatening their license be
removed yeah they've got this going to
be able to do that yeah
that's just basic services they can't
ask them
their obsession cousin Charles is it
very quick I'm on the lives of the
Masters committee and when they do come
up with licensee they do actually tell
us what ports are going and we can put
conditions on that anyway so you know so
it would be a good idea if the 2d ducks
you talk to each other on certain things
like that licensing yes so if they can't
for license already and the John Fowler
yes they will actually tell us the
diners been on this year as well they
will actually come up with Sarah and
tell us what you don't want they on the
board so we can say yes or no if we
agree with it so if they then put up a
big sign it can then go back to nice
it's in like I say okay you revoked it
we've actually agree so you can't have
taken people's asses yeah well because
about because of that so if it's a
licensed premises please obsidian yeah
all this yeah because that taken place
in relation to as well so but we can
explore that yes I'd like to explore as
it's already be just been a lot of the
members yeah how they are I suppose the
reason I'm raising it as a slight
concern is that it's is there in earning
and interpretation of the licensing
committee we think for the adverb okay I
think just to kind of back out I think
for moderately good I think I probably
do speak on proper quite a few other
members
I'll go back to this the first issue is
about perception I think it needs to be
appreciate there's a perception I think
of members of the public that their
neighborhoods are becoming quite
cluttered we don't want to see that
person and such like I think there's a
perception of town parish councils that
they're not really being supported in
their endeavors that have been removed
I think there's a perception from those
that are advertising that actually it's
highly unlikely they will receive any
serious for law enforcement I think the
perception is it's very difficult to
tackle well I think that is the moment
your main problem and I wondered whether
or not you've ever considered that I
know that what the district have
previously run in particular campaigns
have you ever considered running a
campaign that targeted that business is
perhaps reiterated that actually
enforcement is something that's taken
quite seriously hmm I guess you know I
don't know if it's something we've done
previously before one sort of campaigns
where we've made examples particular
bringing your fingers or businesses
there's sort of articles in the press in
recent years about the enforcement
service and that you know unfortunately
I seem to remember that the the idea was
was to promote the fact that you know
enforcement's taken very seriously it's
about upholding public confidence in the
planning system and then the echo
actually reported it as if it's meant to
stay wrong it's not mean if the
authority visual portrait is your
council which I'm assuming they do at
some point or right to every business in
the district other other matters I don't
really see there would be much in
enclosing a leaflet or something from
them just reminding them
keep taking the approach that's been
taken by officers in relation to a
participant's in their interrelationship
with the work jurisdiction of
responsibilities of Essex highways today
there are always competing priorities
for the enforcement team is also
available to carry out this essential
function which I think to know I think
as well one thing that's come to light
this evening okay now regarded by
members is that this area seems to be to
me extremely under staffed and
under-resourced
now wonder what members feelings were
about how to making a recommendation
that perhaps a budget second time the
consideration is given to perhaps
bringing back the member of staff
because let's go I don't know what
members feel about that I know it's cost
implications and if my parents know mr.
what those suggested the recommendation
to is immune thought wasn't really happy
you've written relation to its cynical
one on the previous what anyway
sensually I think he's trying to say
that we did we need more resources if we
want anything done which is what you've
just yet sent his recommendation I think
with rather than paint around the edges
of it we should just say it if that's
what we believe that too
to deal with this issue your resources
speak more straight straightforward bit
more blunt I think it might I mean our
members in agreement that it appears
that this area needs more sources and
yes so well suggesting rather obviously
it's a borstal from saying if we if this
is to be addressed
I would agree obviously it's not
something you just pluck money I know
money sure priorities have to be money
but I think there's a review committee
at least we could do is make a
recommendation that consideration is
given to additional additional resource
[Music]
we only have one item on the key
decisions document the economic growth
strategy which is just um the assembler
executive and there isn't how's Matthew
just to stay but just to outline a
little bit more on it yeah but we
haven't had something in place like this
for a number of years so it's it's an
it's an early stab I might say how we
want to develop a growth strategy we're
looking at it as a live document that we
will develop an update as as those
different areas and sectors that we're
looking to develop as a district become
more apparent to us i I guess as those
elements are explored and how that
relates to how we develop the local plan
and those land uses that might be
appropriate to allocate for various
sectors but it's kind of understanding
the sector's that the authority has that
are growing at present those that we
would like to attract to the area to
diversify the economy and and also
looking you know how ground-level we can
help existing businesses so at the
moment it's it's it's a work in progress
but it's it and I say it's kind of a
live document in the sense that we'll be
developing and seeing as an iterative
process but we want to ensure that we're
supporting business and we're developing
right sectors as we go forward and
that's the intention of this strategy
just very quickly on first of all
speaking of real what sectors do you
want to attract well I guess we don't
want to necessarily compete with other
authorities in South Essex if we're
looking as a whole because some look at
logistics because of their location as
it is at the moment the Business Park is
coming forward and that's looking at
sort of high-tech manufacturing those
areas developing sort of science medical
tech yes yeah I guess these are a
business plan yeah yeah so you know
that's with innings yeah those are the
areas those are the key areas and they
are still the key areas yeah and then
looking how we you know made me
diversify our economy and things like
that because you know we have different
functions within the district the key
function is obviously the Business Park
of making a success of that so alongside
our existing businesses and their
functions there is a key area for
development and and that's not only sort
of a key desire for Rochford but
Southend and others because of the
connection that we have in relation to
the airport as well and what we can make
of that as I say it's a work in progress
to the one again you can see today well
you can stay with the last pillar which
I give up that thing's gonna take very
long on the work plan obviously because
sanctuary housing couldn't make it
tonight
- disseminating members might remember
that we asked residents for suggestions
for January and we had the social media
of the council's communication process
coming to that meeting I'm just waiting
for confirmation the resident that will
be able to attend that meeting and then
obviously Building Control will move
members